All right.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September.
Now February 12th.
There's a fucking comedian.
I don't even know whether I didn't know where the fuck I am.
February 12 2018 what's going on?
How are you?
Um,
usually,
usually I do these by myself.
Usually I'm just sitting alone by,
it's like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
My buddy called me up.
He's got a podcast he wants to promote and he's a fucking eagles fan.
So I figured why not?
I got to go on because for some reason people think I actually fucking hate
Philly just cause I got booed there because of that video.
Yeah.
And it's just like,
no,
I got booed in Philly if I,
if he got booed in Texas.
What do you do?
You make fun of fucking pickup trucks,
chicks with too much makeup?
All of it.
I just make fun of Texas in general.
I think everyone just goes to Texas.
My Goal Goto Stays Kentucky.
I like tech.
Well,
it's Kevin Shay,
everybody from the,
uh,
the Kevin Shea podcasts to all I'm saying podcasts,
all I'm saying,
let me ask it.
That's easy.
Right?
So I remember,
do you know every host in it also kind of gets you off the hook or whatever you
just said.
Exactly.
I all I'm saying it says too many people.
I didn't mean to specifically pick out that group like they needed to go.
But this too.
Any fucking people.
I,
I mean host fucks it up though.
It's,
it's of funny cause they go,
they go with you in trouble.
All of them same podcasts.
I'm saying all I'm saying,
I said you can read it so easy they ass two more times before they go onstage.
And they'd go,
Oh,
I'm talking about what you doing,
how's it going?
And so we know you didn't,
they're getting all Sassy.
Yes.
And we always bet the other,
and all I'm saying isn't really a that's,
that's,
that's pretty mainstream vernacular.
I,
you know,
I didn't,
I thought it was
fucking,
getting a title is hard.
Like you have the best title ever.
It's just the way.
Yeah.
It's simple.
It's so simple.
That's why I did it.
Is that why you remember when it would come out funny and then people go,
we should do one every day of the week.
It's like,
well then it's not the money you got the Thursday.
I do the third Thursday just before Friday and Monday morning podcast.
Um,
I love when people just,
they go fucking all out.
Yeah.
Like you show up some of these comics studios,
you feel like you're doing Howard Stern.
I,
you don't want to be like,
dude,
you can really keep you overhead way.
I look,
I'm not talking about guys like Rogan,
like Rogan in,
we'll have like,
you know,
fucking super,
super famous people.
I'm just talking just like,
oh just emits a jerk off like me and I'm having you over there.
A reason why you're not in my house right now is because my daughter,
I figured that I figured,
cause your daughter's sleeping and then I didn't,
I didn't know you moved.
Like when you texted me the judge in the studio.
I know,
but when you text me me or you mean this,
this still you.
Yeah,
you,
when you texted me,
I was like,
why would he move to Burbank as like,
that was my,
I was like pill.
I was like,
you're doing well.
You got more bang for getting more bang for my buck out saying why would you
move to where I liked the,
I
like the valley.
You know you're getting better,
better conversations out here.
You know what I mean?
You meet some guy who did something on mash way back in the day,
a bunch of Trump supporters.
You know that all that set,
the Hillary stuff gets old man in Hollywood.
It's like,
I get it.
You know what I mean?
I want to hear it.
I want to hear somebody actually thinks something good's going on.
I love it and he's making it better every day.
My burrito takes better.
That's Taco tastes better.
I don't,
I don't really talk to a lot of people.
You know that about me.
Well then why did you come down here?
Oh,
but you,
it's just cause your team just won the Superbowl.
That e a g l e s by the way,
I am con evil.
I'm a fucking huge eagles fan,
but I hate that fucking song.
The fight song fly.
How does it go?
I don't know.
Fly.
It has to be old,
right?
It's not,
it's fucking not,
I did a whole research,
I thought it was from like 1920 or 18 cause it's not fly.
Eagles fly on.
I see.
That sounds like it was written the same week of for,
he's a jolly good fellow
back when that wasn't corny to say.
It's,
it's weird cause it's supposed to sound,
oh it's got the boom boom boom.
Like the jobs up front and it goes get into my head.
I'm low.
So I looked it up [inaudible] 19
five or something like that is like 30 years ago,
32 years ago.
Fuck.
I guess you'd put it this way.
If you were in 1985 right now and that song was 32 years old,
they would have been written in 1953
yeah.
Oh Shit.
But I gotta be honest.
You hit him high,
hit him low is is very like,
still like that sounds like it's written in the forties.
It sounds very college.
No,
no,
no.
I mean college like high school.
I would say college.
Don't be too,
too hard.
Oh No.
I love the song.
I love,
here's the thing.
It's one of those songs where I love that,
but I acknowledge,
acknowledges corny.
Okay.
Do you mean it's cheesy,
but I love,
is it flat?
You go fly up up to this gap.
Is it like a disco remake and like getting uncomfortable?
You seek it.
I'll fucking do you know,
uh,
the Po boy,
he's a jolly good fellow.
The goes one.
The fucking Superbowl number one.
Uh,
we were going to Breyer.
It is like years ago I happened to walk all of those gigs out does drives,
we hate those fucking jobs.
No,
I swear to God,
Dude.
I almost like was ready to fucking just leave la yesterday.
No Way.
I did.
I did that.
It was like fucking Saturday.
It was a Saturday afternoon and I was,
I can rush hour traffic and you want to get mad but you're going to be like,
well I'm also out here and they're all just fucking,
nobody is fucking talking about doing something about this population problem.
And a,
I'll tell you one thing we have to get a problem of is touching the desk and
hitting this.
This is going to be annoying in this.
We have a new podcast studio here.
Oh Shit.
Are we doing that?
No,
I,
I just,
I've been hearing it so we're going to have to put some sort of padding here.
I don't know why,
but anyways,
I like nature,
right?
I enjoyed like watching animals in that
type of shit.
But I always have my,
my,
I never take the remote out of my hand when I watch a nature show cause right
when they start talking about what's going on with them and how they're all
going to die off because of us,
I shut it off.
Well my daughter always takes the remote and it's amazing.
My fucking remote sucks.
I can literally be pointing at the TV,
like change,
change,
what the fuck won't do anything.
My daughter picks it up and he's like walking away with it and we'll both
somehow turn on the fucking DVD player.
I still have one of those.
Um,
is it digital?
Is the remodel all digital?
We're like,
no,
I have direct TV and I love direct TV,
but they're remote sucks.
You look at it,
you have to fucking reboot the thing.
It's like,
it's like a,
it's like it was in a an abusive relationship and it's over sensitive.
I feel like it was recycled.
I'm like some racist had it before me.
It was constantly throwing it at the TVS funny.
And then they just like,
you know,
like all our old phones that you watched a bunch of porn on an aisle over there
and like Thailand and the Philippines.
Do you know how he did you?
Did you have a I have a laptop that I use.
Just report.
Yeah,
I,
I'm very specific.
Just proof or something.
It's just,
it's just the hard job of silt may on a latex.
It's just so old and shot and I don't give a fuck if it gets diseases early.
May suddenly,
yeah,
fuck yeah.
It stays,
it separate.
But it's old.
It's big,
isn't it?
You know what that reminds me?
Have you ever see these people that get like foster kids and they feed their,
they're real kids and they just take the checks for the foster kids.
Maybe the kid will look like he's fucking eight years old when really boning
you'll be like,
how old are you?
And he's like 26.
I didn't know that was a thing.
That is a thing.
Ah,
feed him like fucking paste and shit.
Here's what was confusing when I was younger.
I'm like,
I'm adopted.
I never,
it doesn't surprise me.
The irritating,
I don't know the difference.
I didn't know the difference between foster and adopted.
Okay.
So you thought there was like foster and kid means,
uh,
you just take them for a little while,
right?
Yeah,
but they were always like abused and I was never abused and I couldn't wrap my
brain as a kid.
I called my parents,
mom and dad,
but then my friends down the street who were a family,
but they were divorced with kids,
call them by their fucking names.
While it's great to hear,
that's why they got a divorce.
They were never committed.
They weren't committed to each other.
They weren't committed to having the kids.
It gets weird like when they would call their mom by their first name.
Well My,
well,
my daughter learns how to speak.
I'm going to be like,
this is mister shame.
She's not going to call you Kevin and I don't like that.
I'm like,
I fucking can't stand when people do like my buddies,
we'll talk to you.
Are there other parents and they say,
Hey John Paul,
it's weird.
It would help if we kind of dressed like adults though.
I mean,
you gotta call my hair.
You got to have you go.
You're an adult.
It's not,
you don't have a,
you know what it was.
No,
but back in the day,
like you know,
people just to fucking like if you want,
I was,
I tape recorded all,
like they had all the NFL films,
Superbowls in a row on NFL films and I taped all 51 of them and I'm just working
my way through him.
I love him.
I can't get into the awesome,
they're awesome.
So I was watching him and uh,
first of all,
like the first,
like 11 super bowls were played in like the afternoon.
I know they played like rice stadium at two lane,
you know what I mean?
And there was just like the fucking college band,
like what have,
I'm like the Michigan marching band went out there and play.
Did it?
Uh,
the night I thought you was scatting Horn paid,
I think it would start doing a band or something.
Now you're in my fucking head.
Didn't fit
the niners.
Yup.
They played in Golden Gate Park.
I remember for one of the navy ships and probably an NFL championship,
but you guys sucked back then.
So I don't know.
I think you had like one good year in the forties and 50s.
It was one,
it was one in the fifties.
In the 1960 was the last one.
And we used to,
we always get into this discussion about,
uh,
like you think it matters what the NFL championship,
Nfl titles should count.
They do count,
but they're not super bowls.
And you know,
I don't get that.
You know,
there was no other league.
I get it.
But now there is another league.
There's two.
No,
there's still,
there was,
there was still a fucking no,
you don't understand.
The AFL started in 1960.
Before then there was,
there was only the,
no,
there was the NFL and then the AFL came in.
I'll give you a little history lesson.
One,
the first year of the AFL,
okay.
All the NFL owners laughed.
Bahahahaha look at these fucking morons wasted their money.
But while they laughed at him,
they didn't,
they made two moves to fuck over the AFL.
The first thing they did was,
uh,
I think the team with the most amount of money was,
was that was the Dallas Texans.
They will read and white,
right?
They let him,
he became the Kansas City chiefs.
So what the NFL did was immediately or,
uh,
gave Dallas and NFL franchise.
That's how the cowboy started.
That started so that there would be a team in the same city as the wealthiest
AFL team.
They're trying to cut the head off the snake here.
So then basically the figuring both,
they are going to be low quality of,
of players because they're both brand new.
However,
you could see Jim Brown or whoever,
like the superstar that day was,
would come in and play the cowboys.
So you're going to go to that game rather than the Dallas Texans.
And it kind of worked because the Texans ended up moving to Kansas City and
became the chiefs.
All right.
And then the other move they made was one of their franchises in the Minnesota
Vikings were initially going to be an AFL team.
And they came in and they said,
hey,
uh,
you want to join the NFL?
And then they said,
hey,
fuck the AFL,
let's go with this team.
So that's what they did.
They tried to fuck over to teams.
That's what they did.
Now the NFL continues.
There's all these fucking championships being one.
The Green Bay packers won like 13 of them and they're the New York Yankees.
They're the fucking Celtics there though.
They're the Montreal Canadiens I'll football,
but they just don't recognize their first 12.
So they say the Steelers,
I was six Superbowls.
So in ninth,
after 1969 when the jets beat the fucking,
uh,
no colts was it called?
They beat the colts.
And,
um,
there was a merger talk was already there and the AFL was actually doing so well
and was such an exciting product that it was kind of looking like they might
actually might take over the NFL.
All right.
And the only guy who had the balls to say,
fuck the new NFL merger deal was,
uh,
was,
was what's his face there?
Jesus Christ.
It just based on his name?
Uh,
uh,
with the Raiders.
Oh,
Al Davis.
Al Davis was fuck that.
He just didn't want to beat him.
He wanted to bury him.
He wanted to put them out of business and everybody else was like,
no,
fuck that.
Let's join.
So they joined.
Okay.
Now that has happened in other leagues.
The Nhl with like the Ihl with Wayne Gretzky's where the fuck he played with
India?
Uh,
Indianapolis like um,
I guess that was his first team.
I used to know all of this shit but they,
they've absorbed teams from other leagues.
The NBA took in Aba team?
Yeah.
But they,
they bought,
they still count the Celtics championships but they didn't change the name of
the title.
I think it's cause of the event.
You are changing the name of the title.
I will also say that it is,
maybe that's what it is because you're changing the name of the title.
The basketball never changed the name of the time.
The first two green bay one out where the NFL AFL championship game as was the
third one,
which which jets?
The jets was an NFL NFL title game,
which is Great.
But you know what's funny about,
uh,
the whole story,
you just,
you told me,
I would just say God,
I'm like God,
the Vikings still suck.
But yeah.
Do you know the Patriots now?
You have tied,
they've lost the most super bowls but they also,
oh they don't have these also we bought,
the thing is we've also been to the most,
you've been fucking 10.
We're five and five.
Your tea,
you've been a tech.
Here's the thing I saw is not an NFL fan out there that wouldn't take that
except for the Steelers.
The Steelers or the 49 is in the uh,
the 49.
And the cowboys,
cause they already have five and they've been at like eight or something.
It has been five.
Denver's been to fall river last five.
There's one three.
So they've been to a
cowboys have one five and they'd see they lost to the colts.
They lost to the Steelers twice.
I think that's it.
I think they'd been to eight.
Do
you?
I saw you in clip on
and you go,
Oh,
I've been through five that these losses.
I'm like,
how old are you?
Because the first patriots Superbowl was 86.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Cause I was,
I am old.
I'm turning 50 in June.
Well congratulations.
Yeah,
I turned,
I turned 42 on Friday in America.
Yeah,
you look great.
Thank you.
Considering how much both of us drink,
I mean,
I,
I we're both in good shape too.
I know,
I know.
This is the suck our dicks.
So anyways,
um,
before we get into your big win,
cause I'm really,
cause I gotta be honest with you.
I actually as a spouse,
I'm old enough to remember when all the Boston team's sucked except for the
Celtics eighties,
but then Len bias died and Reggie Lewis,
Diana was just fucking over.
Um,
I,
I remember what it felt like the first time.
So I was actually,
when the Patriots were not looking good to me.
Okay.
You know,
when we played the Steelers and we had the game won and we let up that 90 we let
up 90 yards on a screen pass and then the first year they won.
No,
this year,
this year in December we did that.
Oh,
against the playoff team.
And then they threw a touchdown to win the game.
But the NFL now is like,
oh what did he had the ball?
Did he really have the ball?
So it's not a catch.
But that was,
that game was a fucking loss and that gave us home field advantage and that
helped us fucking go to the Superbowl.
The Superbowl.
Yeah.
So here was the thing,
my,
I was kind of watching you guys cause I was just going,
well who am I gonna root for?
I was like,
oh la rams would be cool if they got something,
the fucking eagles would be cool cause they never won out.
So here's the thing,
if my team is in fucking in it,
I'm going to root for the team.
That is all,
there you go.
I'm going to do it.
I'm not a dick.
I mean,
I didn't do,
Oh,
I'm not a dick.
All right.
So,
but you know,
if it's the Yankees fuck the Yankees and if it's the cadence,
fuck the Canadians and if it's the Lakers fuck the Lakers.
But other than that I got to ask you why,
why the Canadians?
Oh,
Bruins Canadians is okay.
A huge used to be a huge rivalry and what happens is is one team never wins it
and then the other team always wins it and then then what happens is then you
win it and that's the end of the movie.
Then the credits are rolling like they tried to make like the red sox Yankees
thing.
It's not the same.
No,
it's over.
And it's kind of like,
you know when they make the sequel but the star in the movie doesn't sign on to
do it again or like back in the day when like a movie like major league too
without Wesley Snipes.
They took Omar Epps,
slashed all.
He was out.
Okay.
There you go.
Well I would say at Major League without Charlie Sheen.
Yeah.
Okay.
This third one then.
The third load one or jaws three d,
jaws three just to the second Spielberg goes,
Nah,
I'm not doing it.
It just became a,
became the shoes look good.
You didn't like it.
Was that the one?
What was the one with the sharks started roaring?
That was the third one,
right?
It was going like,
ah,
hours on hours.
The one,
the fourth one.
That's bad.
Okay,
that's bad.
Aaron,
you knew that.
That's hilarious.
He just,
he was still immediate with the four.
I was like,
that's why that's so fucking funny.
Everybody looks at shark,
NATO,
like it's this worst thing ever.
It's like,
no.
Do the groundwork had been laid,
but I like that movies.
But let's get back to this real quick.
So I,
so I was going to sit there and you know,
you know,
I got a lot of friends yourself.
Like I have a good half dozen people that I know that are from Philly.
You know,
I,
there's a lot of cool chicks from Philly to that shake.
The women will fill your cool.
Yeah.
So I wasn't going to be that fucking,
you know,
asshole.
So anyways,
so you guys beat us and now you know the deal,
you lose a big game like that.
You go on radio silence.
I'm not going on fucking the Internet.
I mean I kind of still have to because of the podcast,
but I,
I'm not going to watch ESPN so I didn't get to see you guys.
My favorite thing ever is,
is fucking grown men crying over sports is the funniest.
Like that Eagle's fan who called him with Carson Wentz went down.
Did you hear that?
I didn't see that one.
I thought you was the funniest thing is this sportscast it gets like freaked
out.
He's like,
Hey,
he's like buddy,
you crying?
He's like,
oh well we'll win it next year,
man.
Relaxed.
So fight.
Did you see the guy,
um,
uh,
who's waiting at the fence when they won the Superbowl and when they're landing
just to watch,
he was crying.
He was like a 54 year old black dude,
just sobbing black guy.
Yeah.
He's just like my whole fucking life,
my whole fucking life.
And the way,
and here's the eight that Patriot hurts way less now.
They kinda got me.
That hurts way less now knowing that somebody's eagles fan ended up being,
that fucking happened.
Oh,
come on man.
We fucking,
we're drowning.
We're drowning in rings over here,
Kevin.
But here,
here's the thing.
Your first one,
you know,
you know that the game,
I shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
People were losing it.
I was up again when I,
everybody like we were in the exact opposite end zone and he like kicked a field
goal and I'm all right.
I put my hands out like I was holding back the crowd on Beatlemania and my row
because my brother and dad when they was like,
oh fuck,
oh fuck.
And it went through and it just,
I,
I was,
I couldn't believe it when it went through.
Then I saw the confetti and do all of a sudden,
next thing I knew I was on the ground.
What?
I just a whole section just tackled each other.
Oh,
that's fucking insane.
That's fun.
And then I was worried about my dad because I was doing my dad and he was like
in his sixties at the time.
And he got up and he just,
he couldn't fucking believe it.
Right.
And I looked over and there was one guy still standing up.
Yeah.
And he was just standing there and I looked over and he was for some reasons
staring at me and he just had it
tears in his eye and eye eyes kind of locked.
I had to like,
I had
to like look away like,
dude,
what the fuck?
And I remember walking out of the stadium like,
just cause I,
I went to the one we were when we lost to the packers,
so I know what that feeling feels like.
Yeah.
And then when that wasn't it,
but that wasn't close though,
that one.
It was until the opening of the half,
so to have two.
So I basically had faith through fucking 18 and a half games.
So yeah,
it was close.
And then they kick the fucking ball off.
And Tyrone Wheatley.
Oh No,
no,
that was his name.
Desmond Howard.
I know,
I know.
It was a kicker to win a fucking MVP and super kick returner.
Kick returner.
Yeah.
So he ran the fucking thing back right at us.
That's fine.
I might've been in the same end zone.
I don't know.
I both times I had upper deck end zone seats.
So then when we want it,
yeah,
I was thinking like every time the Patriots go,
I'm going at such a great experience.
So the next time we played,
I believe you were playing the panthers and I was going to go,
but it was on Sunday obviously.
And then that Monday we were shooting the world series of dice sketch in the
morning
for a Chappelle show.
Okay.
So I couldn't go and I went there and that's the first time I met Chelsie Murphy
rest his soul.
And A,
I remember being pissed that I could cite to had the act and work.
Obviously it's like to be on the Chappelle show.
But I was like,
fuck man,
I really wanted to go to that game.
But I remember when the game was over and I was in my apartment,
we won.
I was psyched that I still had two grand in my pocket.
I was like,
wait a minute,
this is kind of fucking cool.
So then I was just like,
yeah,
I don't need to go.
I saw the first one ever.
Yeah,
why am I going to go there and use up a ticket somebody else could have and like
someday,
you know,
if I have a kid now I have a kid.
If she ever wants to go,
I'll take her and I'll do that.
But other than that,
you know I'm on the road all the time.
Did you?
You obviously got to feeling I don't,
I don't know if I'd be like if I was at the Superbowl,
my buddies went,
uh Huh.
They lost it.
They lost their minds.
But they actually came back immediately and watched the game cause they said
they couldn't really believe it.
Yeah.
They call it one or two.
They didn't really see what was going on.
Well you don't get the analysis and the breakdown and all of that.
Let me ask you this.
When,
when Brady fumbles the ball and you guys recover,
man,
dude,
what'd you do dude,
but by the way,
are you thinking like,
fuck,
he's going to drive down the field.
We're going to lose?
No,
no,
no.
I never,
this is just crazy.
Normally with all the eagles teams,
I'm like,
ah,
they don't got it right that we're stomach feeling,
but this team,
it was just this this year and I saw destiny.
They lost their fucking quarterback.
I'm getting misty eyed thinking about it,
but then I was like,
ah,
it's not about Tom,
it's about the eagles.
That's how it felt this year about this team.
So when they didn't like how you guys all ran out as a team and it was a Hulu
show
we've been doing that stole I fucking by.
That was our thing,
by the way.
I think it's stupid what the year you guys did it to now I think it's stupid.
I love the intros.
I kind of miss high low.
It was like if I got to tell you,
dude,
we went,
we've gone,
we've gone five and three.
Doing it that way.
We've been to eight of them,
so you might want to keep doing that.
No one else was driving me nuts.
Was Chris Collins with flick up flipping out about that trick book.
I love you the most top level talking to.
He's like,
don't we just ran that fucking play.
But here's the thing,
I saw it.
I saw that clip when you were calling.
You said,
oh I wish Tom Woulda laid out.
I wish he caught it and the only reason cause I wanted to get him,
I want him to get hit.
Oh you did Josh.
Just like,
can I be honest with you?
Yeah.
That guy.
Every fucking Superbowl has driven us down for the win.
Everyone,
you know,
and I actually looked at all the super bowls and I would say that we very easily
could have been seven and one and the one game we should've lost was the Seattle
guest.
Yeah.
It to Marshawn lynch,
both giants games.
We had Brady,
the Welker boom first down over a satay Samuels intercepts the fucking ball to
hit submit both hands.
Yeah,
we got that one.
But that Assad say Samuel,
but this equals one
minded.
I was pretty fucking John by the end of it,
by the end of the game and I just,
I'll tell you,
I never felt good about this.
I never felt good about the team or the game going.
And I said I believe I sent him my podcast.
Take the eagles in the points on the points.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
And I thought you guys had an unbelievable defense.
I'm like these guys,
this is looking like the fucking giant do.
Where was the defects and that game?
It was like a fucking pro bowl by the way.
I've watched the game four times afterwards just to watch it.
Only Tom could have done that.
I guess that defense.
You know what's funny only Tom was is I was watching some of those fucking
passes and how how he got out of the pocket.
Only Tom could have done that.
Well against that defense cause most,
most lie,
most of the wine.
I'll have to watch it again because I didn't think you guys do.
I thought both quarterbacks had like all day.
I don't think he really kept to Brady fucking Nick foals had all day.
Tom got hit like 12 times,
but your line was better than most.
We just didn't have a decent,
I,
I would never question our coaching staff of the Malfoy.
Anytime we do that,
I'm a bad time.
Wes Welker like made all the new when,
when,
uh,
what's his face to find out?
He had the foot fetish.
Rex Ryan,
welcome.
Does this whole interview like sort of giving him shit gone,
you know,
hey,
we're just a,
you know,
you're playing the jets where he says,
yeah,
we're going to put our best foot forward.
That,
you know,
yeah,
it was funny.
And then they kept him out for the first court.
Anytime we do that,
I don't know if we've,
we've probably done that other time,
but they just reminded me of that game.
Be Like,
oh,
we're fucking with the chemistry here,
but,
but I'm a stand up comedian Kevin.
I'm not a fucking offensive coordinator.
So what our defensive coordinator,
what do I know?
But I,
I watched that game four more times.
Like I said,
oh,
it's that I still have the fucking Seattle and the Atlantic.
You still,
you still on my fuck.
I still have it.
I bought,
I got the thing,
never raised him.
My wife's like,
you never going to watch.
He's like,
yeah,
you are.
You will when you're bored or you want to get your fuck his spirits up.
She goes to bed early.
Dude,
I never going to watch this.
I just take the highlights of all 51 foot.
There's like this five losses in that.
Well for losses.
Now we've got a fifth one and I'm still going to watch those.
No,
it's,
it's the best buy.
I'm trying to have a Superbowl 20 we were up three,
nothing against the 46 defense.
Tony Franklin,
speaking of feet,
his bare feet came out and kicked one and I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
I don't embarrass the talking.
All this shit all through that.
That was the most dominant defense that I ever saw.
Here's a good one.
Superbowl six Superbowls six is the Dallas cowboys in the Miami Dolphins.
What's interesting is Tom Landry in Don Shula to legendary coaches.
But when that game went down,
they were both considered losers and like one of them is finally going to get
the monkey off the back.
Dallas had the thing,
they could never win the big one.
And they only been around since 1960 but they lost the ice bowl up in green bay.
I know,
dude,
I'm a fucking nurse.
And then the year before they played the colts,
they got there again and they fucking lawsuit colts in a really messy game.
And then Don Shula,
his big thing was,
uh,
he was with,
he was coaching the 69 colts that lost to the jets.
The first NFL team to lose to an AFL team was a major embarrassment and a,
that ended his career there.
And then he went over to the dolphins.
Wasn't that the undefeated season?
No,
no.
They went,
they went three years in a row,
one of a,
I think two teams to ever go through years in a row.
And only one has ever gone four years in a row.
And that's the,
the bills,
uh,
they lost to the cowboys and then the next year they beat the,
that they beat the red.
Yeah,
they beat the Redskins.
That was the undefeated year.
That was the year that they hadn't before there was 14 to nothing and they would
line it up to kick a field.
Well this is how much of the NFL has changed.
It's like there's like two minutes left in the third quarter and if,
if this thing goes through there,
like the gut notches are going,
this game's over.
It's in the third quarter yet because no one's going to score that.
Mckinsey what all they did was fucking run cause they were like greasy was four,
four,
four and the first quarter.
That's funny.
Do you know what I love?
I love the fact that back then how much cocaine those guys did DOJ ever see that
cocaine cowboys and uh,
the one,
isn't that a movie?
It was a documentary and it was about,
you know,
the cocaine Chaz.
But what the cocaine in the Superbowl,
it wasn't above cocaine trafficking,
cocaine trafficking.
They tell this story about the Steelers and the dolphins and the AFC
championship game or sealers in the Superbowl in Miami.
That entire old line went out the night before and the guy gave them all the
coke.
They wanted to like four in the morning.
That's also a jail bird trying to get into a fucking documentary,
right?
No,
no,
he was,
he was the main guy.
Well,
here's the thing though.
They also,
uh,
like the medical industry,
whatever they call him,
said cocaine is no more addicting than coffee or caffeine.
Yeah.
So that's what they initially said.
If you ever want to read,
uh,
an unbelievable book,
read the Hollywood Henderson,
he was basically the Lawrence Taylor before Lawrence Taylor and he got crazy on
drugs.
And the reason why Lawrence Taylor,
it looks like he just fell out of the sky and no one ever played the game like
that is because Hollywood Henderson messed up his career so bad.
But this highlights of that guy,
that guy was unbelievable.
In fact,
I believe Superbowl 10,
1976,
when he played,
when the cowboys played the Steelers,
they kicked the ball off.
He's a linebacker.
They had him return it and he ran it like 55 fucking yards.
The only person who stopped and was Roy Jarell dove to knock them out of bounds
and had his ribs exposed and Henderson's knees hit him in the ribs in and fucked
him up.
And it caused darella.
This really interesting caused them to fuck up a couple of kicks.
And so that was a big thing for the cowboys.
But they fucked up.
Cause when,
when the second miss or something or the first,
the second Miss Cliff Harris from the cowboys gets in Grl Roger Ellis face going
like,
hey,
you fucked up buddy.
And uh,
Jack Lambert was on the field and just picked fucking cliff Harris up like a
ragdoll and throw him under the ground.
Like basically it's amazing.
Yeah.
And didn't get a penalty.
There's another thing when you watch those old highlight back to,
hey,
knock it off fellas.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck.
Telmate's they bought at Sears.
Brian Dawkins is videos of him.
Suplex and guys,
well,
here's the thing.
The cowboys had that fucking game one in the first half.
They called all these trick plays.
They were loose,
they were throwing the ball,
doing all that they got in the second half.
They played fucking Marty Ball.
And I'm telling you man,
no fucking sport fucks you more when you play.
Not to lose then football.
I don't know what it is that says the falcons are doing.
Granted,
Tom Played fucking lights out,
but you know that's a,
that's a colossal,
it's a clock.
It's a collapse.
I mean,
you know more about football history.
I'm more recent,
but uh,
I don't know shit about football.
I've just watched a lot of video on it.
It's like I watch Superbowl highlights the way Tom Brady,
he actually watched game,
by the way.
I'm not film.
I don't want it.
Here's the,
I like Carson Wentz and you must love Tom Brady.
I don't want to see their personal life.
I don't,
I could give us,
no,
I'm not built that way.
I don't like pre or post game analysis.
Yeah.
I don't like any of that shit.
I don't want,
I don't want to say no,
but I don't want to human moments.
I don't.
This is how fucking,
I don't want to see him as human.
I just want to see them as athletes is,
or the,
I think they're entitled to their privacy.
I get that you should be able to go out as an NFL quarterback and if you want to
go out and do some blow in a,
in a,
in a titty bar.
Yeah.
Here's this what I can't stand about fucking people today with their phones.
If they saw the local quarterback doing blow in a titty bar,
he's fucked.
Rather than thinking,
well,
shit,
I'm here to,
you know what I mean?
No.
I guess they will literally film The fucking guys.
You Go,
Oh God,
I can't believe there's a story quarterback.
They'd say,
what do you do?
You work with heavy machinery.
Yeah.
What the fuck do you do your fucking year in the titty bar to them?
And that's like the whole like,
just let somebody go out,
have a good bucket to,
to shut the fuck [inaudible] telling on everybody.
Just,
they're just so fucking mad being Jimmy John's managers and shit.
It's just like the guy.
If you can be a Jimmy John's manager and you can have a hell of a fuck,
you could tell a week,
you could have a fucking weekend that would make Tom Brady be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Well Tom doesn't do that.
Tom's that doing that to me.
He's not going out and getting fucking nuts.
No,
I'm not saying he is saying he should be able to.
Oh I have a second.
You said that.
All I thought about was Ken Stabler.
I heard this great story.
He used to play for the Oakland Raiders,
uh,
before that horrific trade where they got Dan pastor reading and they switched
in both then he became an oiler and finished up at the saints I believe.
And uh,
he first fullest that today.
Yeah.
No,
I,
that's all I did was looking football course back then.
So it's,
coach was giving him shit one time cause he went up booze in the night before.
He's just like,
he went to fuck you going out partying the night before him game.
He just goes coach,
he goes,
how many hours sleep?
And you need to go play a couple of hours of football.
That's awesome.
And there's nothing to say.
You're right.
You're right on.
Those guys used to go out there and they would just fucking slinging it like,
I don't know.
So anyways,
um,
real quick,
how far into the salary?
Half Hour.
Fuck.
At some point I got to read some advertising.
So when they finally fucking winning,
are you with the other Eagle Fans and you crying?
He attack you in stunned silence by yourself.
Where did you watch the game out of it?
Do you remember that casino we played in San Diego.
We flew in a helicopter.
It's north.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
you were there.
So we were there.
The girl,
I'm dating the girl,
I'm seeing the lady friend,
she's like,
I know you're not going to want to be around anyone,
so I'll get your old tail.
So she got us a hotel and then she's like,
I want to sit by the pool.
So I'll rent wellness.
The cause a cabana with the TV.
It was fucking awesome.
We had a whole entire Gravana just to herself.
I don't want to put any pressure on the relationship or you've got to marry that
girl.
I couldn't believe it.
She goes,
she's a Steelers fan.
She loves softball too.
But she goes,
I get it.
She goes,
this is your fucking day dude.
She's an understand.
I know I could.
How many times have you said to a woman,
I get it and you were right and you made their day.
No,
I'm telling you what she,
I said to assign a woman that gets it and I totally said to her,
I go,
you can totally buy my love.
I'm all,
I'm all for it.
So I never daydream.
Classic Guy.
She does something great to say with something sweet.
Yeah.
And you made it seem so hook a rich maybe.
Little bit.
So I,
I don't ever day drink.
That's one of the reasons why the Rosebowl thing is out the window.
Cause I,
I'll give you see me when I'm drunk.
Do you think that's why you've never been?
What do you mean?
Because the reason why they're actually,
I'm going to come clean.
Okay.
We've never had you there.
Well,
the first couple of years,
no,
you've never been there?
No,
no.
I'm saying the first couple of years you said,
hey come.
I said,
I don't think I got to know you better.
I told you.
And then we had a talk.
We embarked on it.
We're like,
no,
listen,
we love Shea.
But that year we bring Shay is the year we get kicked out.
Yeah.
And the first quarter,
and I emit,
I told you guys that I even told far lane I go bar in it.
And if you,
if I come and I'm surgery in at 10,
oh it's done 10.
So we say we get on,
it starts,
how the fuck do you even go to the game?
I'm always blown away.
I literally drink,
pass out,
wake up with a hangover and recover before the game even starts.
I still can't believe its Sunday.
That's amazing.
I always fall asleep on when lie had light.
Always make some fucking insane.
Uh,
like for the,
for the main course,
I never make it to the main course.
I always wake up,
I always wake up.
It's already over.
I mean,
one year I was so shit face.
I actually had the afternoon a cigar first and then all of a sudden he brought
over like a pork shoulder and I was smoking a cigar shifts.
I'd eat pork shoulder with my hands and occasionally I would look up and see
families walking by with children.
Oh my gosh.
It's just like,
wow man.
I remember going to Sullivan Stadium back in the day and seeing like me.
That's amazing.
Oh real quick.
So I got wasted and define yourself by,
what are you drinking?
Jameson soda all the time.
James and soda.
And she's in the room.
The bed still made,
right?
Oh No,
no.
I'll come back and seeing the Cabana Cabana.
That's like a man with no shirt,
just shorts,
no shoes,
a hat and just a drink of my left hand.
And then there's other command and next to us was all patriots fans.
They were all like big white dude.
Oh God.
But they were great.
They were like,
nice guys.
Cause I,
I became the loud one.
Obviously I became nuts.
So there's one guy who was like this big fat white dude,
the beer.
Every time you walk by the table go pass.
I go,
Eh,
I couldn't even speak.
I was just so like angry.
I'm like,
Eh.
So at the end of it,
well he's bringing a coat.
Yeah,
I know he's been a cop,
but he actually came up with fat white country.
Yes,
exactly.
But he came over and he was really cool.
He shook my hand and congratulated me.
But by the end of the game,
dude,
I lost it.
I sort of thought the flip it over the lounge chairs.
Oh God.
Yeah.
You know why?
Cause I was just fucking excited.
That's,
that's how I get.
So I just started flipping over.
Do you think that that eagles fans are really that bad or the rep was there,
so now they just try to find the guy eating horse shit.
You gotta Admit Horse Shit's pretty big.
Oh fuck.
Wars fans are bad.
The whole life.
Eagles fans are pedestrian compared to out here.
Fucking,
you can get killed out here.
A guy got killed at a Dodgers game,
dude.
He goes by,
they'll throw full beers at year,
they've dump went over your head.
You want to get to a fist fight.
They'll do that.
They'll eat to farm animals.
Shit evidently stab at a Raiders preseason game like Raiders 40.
Niners fuck cares.
I'm so sick of the fucking snow balls Santa,
you know,
when it was making fun of who gives up anytime you guys are in a big game,
like the,
the big cheesy thing.
Whenever Boston is in a big game,
uh,
what they talk about is they'll talk about,
um,
you know,
they'll show like fucking the Paul revere statue or something in the north end.
All this shit that nobody from Boston ever went to unless you went on some field
trip that you've,
that would probably psyched as a kid because you didn't have to go to school.
The freedom trail and the foliage and fucking some lobster fishermen tightness,
sailors not,
I don't even know why.
I didn't even know what they do.
You guys,
it's always God.
You know what it is?
What is it?
Rocky Statue Philly.
She's dating.
Yes.
I'm like,
did you just say [inaudible] is a fucking Tyler,
go to Philly.
Next time I go to Philly,
I'm going going on one of those fucking cheese steak places.
I want to say this.
Hello.
I would like a Philadelphia cream,
uh,
Phyllis Philadelphia cheese steak sandwich with peppers and onions and provolone
cheese.
Please.
I'm so sick of them telling me how to ideally a Wiz with,
I'm not saying that his so soup.
I have legal tender.
Make me a fucking set a trap.
It's the only city that's like the Hoe and Boston.
You want some clam chowder and you got to go so stupid.
I'm like,
I don't care.
I love Philly cheese steaks.
I'm from Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania.
I love,
but I don't love him enough to say this is what I'm about.
I'm not a fucking Hoagie.
Can I tell you something to do?
Oh God,
I hate clam chowder.
Clam chowder tastes like it was in,
you know what it tastes like.
Fixtures.
Nobody's,
you know what I just said?
Shit.
That cow's chew.
When are they in between their three stomachs and they just a yak and a bolt.
That's what the fuck it tastes like.
You took it to another level.
Uh,
I liked clam chowder.
Fish just fishes to me.
It still seems like it'd be clear or else across every part of the ocean would
be foggy
there.
Exit clear.
They got clear.
I like,
I like clam chowder and I don't even like Milky Shit.
I'm like lactose intolerant.
I liked clam chowder,
but it's not a big deal.
Like Philly cheese steaks out.
It's just so fucking nuts.
And they show it cooking like then cooking it or cut of meat.
I actually been,
I liked,
I really liked cheese steaks,
but uh,
I just hate that whole fucking thing.
You got to say it this way now.
I don't,
I,
I haven't played Philly's so fucking long.
I don't,
I never eaten at any of those places.
All right.
Yeah,
I stay away from it.
I gotta I tell you something.
I had a fucking,
you know,
when I look at this old truck,
so I listen to fucking am radio.
So it's just either sports talk,
uh,
somebody's speaking some sort of Korean or like political shit,
right wing stuff.
So I'm listening to sports talk and they were talking about that,
whatever that fucking,
whatever our coordinator's name is Josh or some shit.
He interviewed annuals.
Yeah,
I interviewed for the colts job.
Oh,
all of that.
All of that shit.
And then he walks away the last second and then,
then they're talking about it and this one guy's going like it,
you know,
there's not nothing illegal bar.
Oh,
I don't like the way it went down,
but blah,
blah.
And this other guy on the show,
he goes,
this is just indicative of a,
the Patriots,
once again,
bending the rules.
It's like,
you've gotta be shitting me.
It's like they'll,
the level that people didn't pay attention to deflate gate.
It's like what that guy did to us,
if that's all we do.
Back to,
let's just say that was a conspiracy.
Okay,
Josh,
you're going to go in there and even though we're preparing for the Superbowl,
fuck all of that,
we're going to have this big conspiracy and we're going to just waste it.
Fuck a time if that's all we did to them,
he got off easy because this a million dollars and to draft picks over some
bullshit.
Ah,
you guys deserve that.
Why I'm fucking with you.
Yeah.
All right.
But here's the thing,
uh,
with the hope and you had a point,
I could actually become the piece I my favorite thing,
but cherry on top,
that story,
the Cherry on top of that story is not that the fucking idiot found deflated
balls on the cold side too.
It's that the fucking guy in the colts that caught the ball,
the initial one that started all that bullshit.
Electric plus this.
Yeah.
That guy.
You know what he did in the next year,
the two years within that he tested positive for steroids where it was ESPN.
There you,
you still are mad.
You won the Superbowl that year like that.
No,
he didn't.
He did.
He days.
Remember we did it for four years,
was talking about the suspension or placate happened and then that.
Then the next year,
like he got his fucking suspended.
Then they went to court,
blah,
and then it got up there and then he got fucking suspect.
He got laughed out of court.
The judge was mad.
You're wasting a fucking time.
Then the NFL was butthurt that we beat them and then they fucking come back and
they guard is the NFL Corporation?
Yes.
Is Tom Brady employee does a corporational right to suspend an employee.
That's how they spend and they find a loophole.
Thani got suspended.
It was like three years of shit.
Fair enough.
But we wasted fucking a week of that guy's life and fucked him over with season.
Fuck that guy.
All right.
Fair enough.
I don't like to cook.
I don't like to colts.
I agree with you,
but you got to soup.
I don't mind.
Cold fans will fans.
I don't really,
do we want to work?
Can we would've got the fucking Superbowl anyways.
Yeah,
we know.
We did do
and then the 49 is when it had to spend all that money on.
A guy was played five games.
Oh,
Groppe.
Hello Jesus Christ.
That,
what are they doing?
What's going to be good?
You know,
he's going to be good.
Grew up alone to okay.
He,
he's,
he,
he looks like he's going to be God dude,
this Benz,
I'm not saying he's not going to be good,
but dude,
that guy's making more money than like Aaron Rodgers.
I,
you know what,
I do disagree with you.
Tom Brady would not have played as well if he does get suspended those first
four games two years ago.
I listen,
I will say this,
I liked,
uh,
39,
four year old guy getting four games off.
He,
I like,
that's great,
but I don't think it added any more.
He,
he,
it,
he's like psycho driven.
Anyways.
My only thing about him is I don't want him to go out like Brett Farve.
I don't cause this whole fucking thing,
Tom versus time.
If he plays these 45,
you know,
as long as he's still competitive,
I just don't want to see him like on the rams,
like Joe Nemeth fucking Johnny Unitas wearing a fucking charges uniform.
He's too proud.
He won't,
I hope he doesn't do that.
Why the fuck is he doing this weird reality show?
I don't get it.
What is,
what is it?
I'm not going to pay attention to it,
but that makes me fucking nervous because he never did shit man.
He did like 400 commercials a year.
I thought that helped us.
Yeah,
because painting is kind of like to every guy,
like he comes off like a dumb farmer.
I mean people like that and the fucking Midwest.
I fucking hate can't,
I don't like to cults in general.
I don't have to beat the chargers.
That's what I would have sunk.
Somebody has speak today like,
hey,
you know,
where does,
uh,
where does it,
this is just going to be all football talk.
Where does,
where does,
uh,
you know,
Tom Brady having the greatest coach of all time in the,
in the brief versus Peyton manning argument.
And that's a fair point.
But,
um,
I be honest with you.
I actually liked Eli.
I would rather have had eli in January.
Yeah.
Eli's a better,
uh,
play off quarterback Eli.
His breath stink in September,
October.
But then when,
you know,
I need him to turn it off.
Turns it on.
Dan Marino.
Wouldn't you say paid man?
He's the greatest regular season quarterback of all time.
Uh,
first of all,
Dan Marino gets an unbelievable bad rap.
Okay.
Peyton manning was part of a three headed fucking monster.
All one that said will no just by Edgerrin James and,
and,
and what's his face there?
Wide Receiver.
Just forgot his fucking name.
Marvin.
Marvin Harrison.
Well,
I never had his football card,
so I'll never remember.
All right.
Shot two people.
No,
he didn't.
He,
he allegedly,
allegedly,
allegedly let you think.
Well,
maybe the,
maybe the eight is horseshit and he was upset.
Um,
they fucking,
Dan Marino had no running game and no defense.
Yes.
Great.
His entire career.
What was he supposed to do?
I'll tell you about Tom.
Brady would not have won a fucking super bowl with with fucking and Don Shula.
Everybody stole all his tricks.
By the time the two devil,
Rita would've thrown easily per 6,000 yards in today's NFL.
Well,
today's NFL.
Do you like it now?
No,
I don't like it.
They went too far and when I'm liking about watching these first Superbowls is I
like more the running.
I liked the diff defenses,
had nicknames and stuff.
It was,
it was a meaner game and it was a more strategic game.
And to Paul verse,
he said the funniest fucking shit about that Eagle's patriots super Superbowl.
He's like,
dude,
he goes,
that's the kind.
That's the kind of game you're girlfriend likes that.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like if soccer had that much storing,
I'd be like,
dude,
that was a great fucking gay.
All those English guys who'd be like,
well,
I made it fucking by the day,
but they would be able to break down the game as to why suck.
Everyone keeps telling me what a great game.
Congratulations.
I'm happy because the Eagles won.
I'm happy.
But it wasn't.
It was a shit show was a great game though.
Fucking defects that I said it was viewer friendly.
Yeah,
it went and I have to be honest with you,
that is all those rule changes.
I always blame to Marissa cause I'm a con,
but it's all of them.
It's because they're trying to expand the game and you know that they've done
studies and you know that offense sells the game.
That's why I think MLB looked the other way when everyone was all roided up and
they actually asked surprise.
All the owners get to act surprised.
Like,
oh we had no fucking idea.
I really like,
we don't know the comic set up partying.
The MLP doesn't pay.
The guy had zillion dollars a fucking year.
You don't know what he's doing.
Um,
but the NBA,
but that game was fucked.
That that when they had the strike and they didn't have the world series and all
of that shit,
they needed something to come back.
By the way,
that was a fucking awesome year though.
It was like,
it was fucking,
it was,
it was fucking amazing.
I remember Washington College,
every lunch,
every year in the cafeteria,
we'd watch the fucking highlights like who I went to.
Like I never,
I went to the same one when Mark Mcgwire hit his 27th or 28th home run.
It was down in San Diego and they're still playing at Qualcomm stadium as a
chef.
I went there with this comic Dan Smith that we sat in the upper deck and when
fucking Maguire do,
but the place was packed for his,
uh,
for his,
when he would take batting practice and the whole place,
he came up to the plate for batting practice,
standing ovation.
It was like three quarters for batting practice.
Everybody's going nuts and it's the funniest shit ever.
The first pitch in,
he laid down a bunt and everybody booed and then he laughed and everybody
laughed because it was kind of a cool way to get rid of the stress.
It let me,
I got to read a couple of,
uh,
advertisements here and then I want to talk about what's going on with
mailboxes.
I'm going to talk to you about it.
All right.
The Black Tux.
Everybody.
Kevin.
This is the black Tux.
The like the Ohio state.
You heard Greg Wilson,
the Greg Wilson.
I love the Greg Wilson.
He's a nut bag.
Yeah,
he's the best.
Uh,
everyone wants to look as great as their date at a wedding or special event.
Now they're talking about wearing a dress.
Trouble is,
there's no way you want to spend the amount of time or money.
She's,
she did shopping for outfit.
I can't read out loud.
By the way,
the black box.com is your answer with high quality rental suits and Tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux is the easy way for guys to rent suits and Tuxedos online suits.
Usually retail for 1200 bucks.
But at Black Tux they start at just $95.
God Damn Huh.
I'm going to get a Tuxedo.
Wear it on my podcast expert customer care has your,
has your back every step of the way.
Completely done online with the Black Tux.
Free home.
Try on.
You can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit.
After ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything else is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
And when your event's over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
That's gross.
Shipping is free both ways.
Big Manila envelope,
uh,
to get $20 off your purchase,
visit black docs,
black tux.com
that's the black tux.com/birth the $20 off your purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
I love when people laugh at my reads when it's live.
It's too,
it's too hard to say.
What is that?
The Black Tux.
Z black black.
That's why you gotta go.
You gotta chop it up.
The Black Tux,
the top crop.
You Iceberg.
Here's another one.
Here's a note.
Simply safe.
I know this,
I've got some exciting news.
Simply safe home security company I've worked with since there we,
they were a startup.
Who the fuck was this for?
Um,
I've watched them transform into that.
Why do they do this?
Okay,
look,
they've transformed into the fastest growing home security company in the nation
protecting over 2 million people while they just released their brand new home
security system.
The all new,
simply safe.
Now this is the shit I'm into.
You got to have a home security system at this point,
right?
I don't understand what they do.
You don't understand what they do.
Well,
I'm glad you asked.
You'd be great on an infomercial.
Wait a minute,
but does the AEC stick to the pan?
Of course not.
Just watch,
Kevin.
This system has been completely,
completely rebuilt and redesign.
They've added new safeguards to protect against power outages,
down Wifi,
cut land lines,
bats,
hammers,
and everything in between.
You remember the end of Scarface?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
he wasn't doing all that blow.
That was a simply safe system and they saw all those fucking people come on over
the wall.
But Tony was too busy partying all night.
What do you want the fuck me,
Tony.
The all new,
simply safe was redesigned to be practically invisible with the powerful sensors
so small.
You'll hardly notice them.
You know who will intruders.
This is what truly remarkable to me.
Evidently simply safe spent years building the system.
They added so much more.
How weird was that fucking scene that that poor actress had to play?
You want to fuck me,
Tony?
That was hot.
Now I know why you have a private computer from the porn,
but you will still get the same fair,
honest price.
24 seven protection for only 15 bucks a month and there's no contract.
It's smaller,
faster and stronger than anything they've built before,
but it's the supply is very limited.
Visit simply safe dock birth Jesus.
Visit simply safe [inaudible] dot com now to order that's simply safe.
bird.com to protect your home and family today.
Simply safe bird.com one more.
Can you,
can you sit here and I like it.
I can I interrupt her?
No,
no,
no.
You're listening to Howard stern a little bit.
I like her.
Just said,
I don't like that.
You're like,
I like a stamps.com stamps dot comes easiest.
It's the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post office.
Print postage.
For any male class,
right from your own computer,
the exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay again.
stamps.com saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using my computer and my printer.
Um,
and the mailman comes and picks it up the mail,
man,
the mass tag me to a stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the u s
postal service right to your fingertips.
Tips and pie is print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer,
they'll send that you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best class of mail based on
your business needs.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters,
I have a myself,
I love stats on mold and groped by fucking cougars that never,
never,
never.
They brought to hunting trend to stamps.
Um,
well,
I don't know.
You fucking use a computer.
You have your assistant do it.
That's what you do actually.
And right now.
You too can enjoy some of somebody born in the 90s you have do it and right now
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital sales scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top of the homepage,
type of bird that stamps.com enter bro.
Use Your computer and your printer.
That's how you do it.
I don't printer then you use,
you don't have a printer printer.
All right.
You went negative on all the ads.
Getting a talk.
Don't need a home security system and everything.
You don't mail shifting mail?
Shit,
I don't mail shit.
I returned.
I the only time I ever mail shit I have to return a fuck.
How do you pay bills online?
You Pay Online?
Yeah.
And do you use like your banking online?
Do you not do that?
No.
Do you?
You do not fucking mail checks all the time.
You fucking with me?
No.
Do you know,
do so you need so that way we're holding.
I'm one of the last ones because one's going to say is no fucking this starting
to get rid of mailboxes.
They're starting to weld them shut.
You go up to one,
you're like,
oh good and then you can't get it in there.
What?
Yeah,
they're going away like remember those,
those,
those phone boosts,
the big red phone booths that they had an England.
Yes.
And now for some reason they sold all of them over here because we're weird and
we want to so they turn those in a new mailboxes I think.
I think a bunch of people in England are going to buy an old post office boxes
and so much as they come in their man caves so and just bought the La Times.
So how the fuck are we going to get the La Times if there's mailboxes don't
work.
Don't you have a paper boy?
One of his no paperwork was there.
I do see,
I see a Mexican moms driving their kids around in the mornings when I wake up in
the mornings and they fill their fucking paper.
God bless him.
And my dad used to do this with us.
That's why I have the work at [inaudible].
I had,
I had a paper from third grade until the point it got weird.
Yeah,
you got my voice was starting to change.
I couldn't walk away from the money.
All my friends were always broke.
I do.
They had no overhead football cards and candy where my biggest fucking
expensive.
So that was it.
I wouldn't life be great if we could just go.
You still ride my bike up to the bowling alley.
Go Bowling.
I paid for the whole fucking thing.
No.
Yeah.
Never had to go to my parent Haney and any key me couple of bucks,
man.
Never had to do that.
I was fucking independent.
You go and bill,
I got on a bike ride.
All right.
Get the fuck Outta here.
They didn't give a shit and we were,
we were born and you were,
but you were exhausted at score guarantee.
I wasn't,
ah,
you were up at like four in the morning.
I rode a bike.
I didn't go boozing as I was a kid.
My,
but my body was brand new.
All right.
Premiere League football.
People write in,
they ask questions and all this shit.
All right.
Oh Nice.
I like this premier league football.
Um,
the premier league,
if I swear to God,
a level of excitement.
Like whenever I put these games on,
every time when I watch him,
like,
you know,
they love it.
I can get into it and it's always that.
It's always like nighttime and shit.
Now it makes you want to Bose.
You wish it was cold.
I you stuck on half and hang up.
I kinda,
my scarf is as I started singing some songs.
I hate to be the coach,
say American,
but I don't want to get soccer.
Um,
sir,
William of Albino.
Phil,
that was actually for you.
It's a great one.
They usually just go,
hey Billy,
read Ted.
Say You freckled con.
You know,
it's the usual.
I'd like that sir.
What?
My Bell Vinyl Ville.
Um,
that's almost begging for a picture.
I think I got to dress up in a regal way.
I got to make sure we wrap this up because I'm going to go see a Todd rhexis.
He wrecks and he sold out both of his shows over,
sold them.
So thank you to everybody.
Listened to Todd on this show and bought a ticket.
All right.
There is only one team you can support in the English premier league and that is
Liverpool.
It.
And I'm just going to pause and wait for everybody in England list.
Oh fuck.
Fucking kinds.
Beatle mania.
It is deeply working class with a long Irish history.
All right.
I'm in.
The city itself doesn't consider itself English,
but a separate entity from the rest of the country.
I'll grow the fuck up.
What are you,
the south,
you're going to secede from the union.
Liverpool football club is currently owned by Fenway sports group,
La.
That's the red sox.
That's it.
Yeah.
Up until recently we were the most successful team in England,
but a barren,
spelled due to tragedy and mismanagement finally seems to be coming to an end,
much like the red sox during they're winless run.
Um,
so why the fuck do I want to jump on the bandwagon now we have the most exciting
attacking line in the league,
possibly Europe.
Our manager is an utter lunatic,
a very rich history.
Okay.
I'm kind of in right now.
Not all of it is good.
Uh,
including 18 league titles and five European cups.
The best team in the whole of Europe is European Cup.
We've been targeted by the press,
the media,
and even the government.
Oh,
this is like the Patriots.
Let us see.
I'm a fucking Liverpool Fan.
This isn't a franchise bill.
Once you pick your team or once your team picks you,
that's it for life.
No changing,
no moving cities through good and bad up the reds,
Billy boy.
Hey,
I don't switch.
Teams don't even fucking suggests that I do that.
You fucking cunt.
Quite a,
yeah.
I was going to pick Liverpool just cause I liked the Beatles.
He was just trying to get you to switch to Liverpool,
my favorite Beatle song of all time.
Uh,
we,
we uh,
isn't that them?
Uh,
we,
we uh,
the beet hoes.
All right views.
Do you get into soccer at all?
A little bit.
Well,
a little bit.
World Cup,
World Cups,
kind of fun.
Except that one year,
that one year in Africa when they had us fucking horns.
What were those things?
Ah,
I don't know.
I didn't watch much of that instrument if like a Kazoo fucked a bagpipe
and Yoko ono played it right.
Uh,
views on public speaking fees.
Hey Bill,
longtime fan and listener and I always enjoy your point of view on things that
he just went straight ahead.
Yeah,
there you go.
Anyways,
was listening to the most recent,
uh,
Monday morning podcast and I was surprised to hear your point of view on
speaking fees considering that you are in essence a public speaker.
I guess that you have some understanding how much more money this is relative to
other named acts.
I would be curious to see how much money other famous people get to talk if you
knew those without naming names.
Apparently Obama gets 400 grand per speech.
Uh,
no,
I'm not a public speaker.
I'm a con.
I'm a comedian.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
at that point,
like somebody going like,
Eh,
you know,
extracts.
Damn.
You know about it.
I don't like the ones who like,
like motivational speakers.
Yeah.
There's a reason that someone's called a public speaker.
What do you mean?
Well,
because they're boring and they're not funny.
You're called the community.
We're actually entertaining.
It's like Ted talk.
Yeah,
no,
my problem that I had with these guys,
say like Obama,
where everybody's looking at this guy like he's a fucking saint is he's doing
what all of these guys do.
They all go into public office.
They say they're there for the people.
And by the,
by the end of his administration,
he was already worth $80 million when he was making like four,
500 grand a year.
But she can make some,
everyone wants to make money.
No.
Oh yeah.
But I mean,
they,
they should give the president fuck you money.
I'm not obsessed.
It's the fact that I don't have the money to be like,
Hey Obama,
when you know a Trump,
when you get novelists,
uh,
make sure that comedy club always has fresh Calamari,
his fucking 10 million bucks.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like they do,
except they do it or not fucking global level.
Is he asking how much performers get paid?
I don't know what he's,
I don't know what the fuck is asking.
On the flip side,
should we even care how much money they get after they're out of office,
sir?
Yes.
Oh,
you have to do,
how does the president get into office?
How does he afford to get into office?
He needs people to make campaign donations.
All right.
And when these fucking rich people make the donations and then after we're,
after they're done and he does everything that they want to,
then they go on the tour.
That's them washing their bribe money.
Hey,
I'm going to give you a 400 grand to give an hour long speech there.
The whole spill.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's so fucking out.
That's what it is.
I'm not,
I'm not upset that this guy,
I'm not upset that anyone can go out and make money.
It's just the fact that you've got these guys,
they need $100 million to get a job that pays for 500 grand a year.
And before the g they're making 500 grand a year.
And by the end of it,
they are,
they're already worth like 80 million bucks.
Like,
how the fuck did that happen?
Does that happen?
How does that happen?
The someone should get to the bottom of how the fuck does that happen because
it's all fucking corrupt.
Um,
that's my problem sir.
And I think they'd be the only true,
like really decent,
like truly public servant that I've seen as a,
as a president in my lifetime was Jimmy Carter.
I'm not saying he didn't go out and do public speeches.
I didn't even look up to that.
But the guy has spent his fucking,
his golden years where he could just be sitting there painting like fucking,
uh,
George Bush.
You know,
he can be out there tagging broads like Clinton,
he's he phase fucking building and he's for the home.
The shaking hands on an airplane too.
He's a fucking great dude.
Is that the guy?
Yeah.
You know what's funny?
You know it's funny.
He was the most human,
you most humane guy I've seen and,
and,
and he was considered to an absolute pussy,
but we know that's the truth.
That's how it works.
You can't be nice and not be considered a positive.
You can be,
you could be that.
You can be a decent can be.
Decent thing about it is,
is he was nice enough when that whole fucking around shit what your hostage is
went down.
He settled that without getting dragged into a war.
So it was considered a pussy because big business could have gone in there and
made that money,
you know?
Yeah.
That's kind of not have to wait for another event to go in there and try to get
a bunch of fucking oil.
Alright.
Cheating with a boyfriend.
Yeah.
He's,
here we go.
Uh,
hey Billy burger.
It's cold so we fuck no,
no,
no.
That's making fun of my last name.
Oh,
okay.
That takes me back to like grade school.
All right.
I'm a female.
I got a lady,
right?
And then by the way,
dude,
you're a fucking great gas man and you're a fucking great comedian,
Kevin.
You got to see Kevin Shay and listen to the old fuck dog.
Why wait,
wait,
wait.
Alls I'm saying,
oh.
I'm saying,
oh no ass.
He goes,
what?
I'm saying?
Uh,
and w were you performing next?
I'm at the Ice House Tuesday to give.
Give me a fucking paid Gig,
man.
Oh Shit.
Um,
West Palm beach this weekend,
but that's a,
I'm with Ken Jong Kitchen.
All right.
The guy from a hangover or there you go.
There you go.
The improv that yet west Palm Beach.
You see?
Go to Kevin shade.com.
Go to Kevin.
Shade that TV.
Some fucking white guy in upper upstate New York has given shape.
Kevin Shay.
Dot.
TVS and go down.
Check him out.
He's fucking hilarious.
All Right,
Bill,
I'm a female.
The story isn't about me.
It's about my friend.
Uh,
that's a lie.
I know my friend wants to fuck around on her husband were in our early twenties
and have been friends since high school.
We've always been there for each other and even though our friendship has been
long,
it has been long distance since then.
However,
now we have a slight problem.
Uh,
she's been dating a guy for a year and they've been butting heads lately.
One night she got high with her roommate who's a guy and they started to kiss
and then of course one thing led to another.
Apparently her roommate has been having feelings for her for a long time and
wants to be in a relationship with her instead of just banging her.
Uh,
she broke up with her boyfriend using their conflicts is the reason is set of
saying she cheated and we've all done that.
Every lie.
Um,
all three of them have been,
have a bunch of mutual friends,
so she wants to lay low.
And the fact that she cheated,
she also wants to give her now ex boyfriend time to heal before he finds out she
staying in a roommate.
This is called being a class act.
Why bring extra hurt,
right?
Yeah.
But why not?
I mean,
at this point she's feeling guilty.
Just fucking say it.
That's easy to say at our age.
But when you're young,
when you're young.
Yeah.
Okay.
When you're younger,
you don't know how to do it.
But she doesn't even have,
she doesn't even know that it's obviously her shoes.
Right.
Well,
let's going here.
I keep trying to tell her that it'd be better to come clean about what she's
done now than to wait it out.
I know whatever their,
whatever their gender,
I know people in whatever their gender have the ability to cheat.
Growing up,
I've seen how being cheated on has affected people around me,
including myself.
I never thought that she would be the person to cheat.
So my question is,
I had people cheat,
whatever.
And then like now she's judging her.
Uh,
so my question is how can I get it through her head and she needs to handle this
situation better,
but also be a good friend to her at the same time.
Uh,
if need is there and has any vice,
who would be great,
thanks.
And Go fuck off.
Fuck yourself a second date problem.
Oh,
this is a different one.
Um,
you know what?
I think you need to butt out.
Yeah.
Okay.
If we,
if we actually think this isn't about her,
which I don't,
I think it's about her and someone saying that to her.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
if it's,
if it's you,
if is this is actually,
I don't think she would've worded it that way.
I believe it.
Okay.
If we believe it,
it's a none of your fucking business.
You know,
people make mistakes.
We're all human.
You know what I mean?
So if you,
if you're a good,
this is the actual job.
If you're a real fucking friend,
you wouldn't judge her.
Can I tell you something?
Yeah.
Once you get past the pain,
she did you a favor.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
you weren't married,
didn't have any fucking kids.
You didn't have a house together and all that.
So who gives a fuck?
And then she,
you know,
do I already butting heads?
They weren't getting along.
It was the end and there were 22 that it's already over relationship.
And you'd go,
fuck somebody.
I mean,
it's still like girls.
Do you know what that's like?
It's like an empty net goal,
you know what I mean?
I mean a lot it,
but I mean,
you know,
you didn't fake out a goal.
If
it's garbage time,
we've got all the is on the bench.
It's garbage.
It's garbage time.
Fucking,
you know what?
You have you ever,
that's it.
I've done it all.
Got found out later that I got mad.
I was just like,
Eh,
he's a fucking was over.
Is it one more than that?
Whatever time you were in a relationship as it was over a half.
Like if you're in four years,
it's been done for two years.
Does that make sense?
I would say a year and a half year and a half break ups just don't happen
overnight.
You don't wake up like,
you know what?
I'm fucking Outta here.
You draw it out,
you start to get distance.
You start fucking Shit fucking course on how to break up in high school in high
school should they should teach young people that are doing it would be so much
better.
I think just so you don't fucking drag someone along or you don't get dragged
along.
Well,
all you had to do is you just got to sit down.
I've been one time I had to get out of relationship and I remember,
uh,
Steve Byrne had just got out of one.
This is like fucking,
you know,
years ago,
2025 years ago.
Right.
And,
uh,
not 25,
like 20 years ago.
And I literally asked him,
I was like,
what did you say?
He goes,
I just sat down.
It's said,
I just said I'm not happy.
That's what he started with.
And I've given that advice on here,
cause I used that.
I don't think I ever told him that.
I just fucking used it.
I don't,
I,
we need to,
I'm just not like,
yeah,
I just,
you know,
it's,
it's just not working.
It just doesn't feel right.
I'm not happy.
This is the thing,
but this is the thing,
you have to get it all out.
Yep.
And I think we should break up and you got to like,
I think you'd just go bump,
bump.
It's like monkey bars,
boom,
boom.
Get across it and then you say,
we got to break up and she's going to drag you through it like 50 fucking times.
It's like lying to the cops.
You just stick to your fucking story.
Yeah,
it's,
but that whole,
I'm not happy.
I've heard it and I've said it usually drags out for seven more months.
No,
no,
but that's,
you know,
we're not happy.
It's not working out.
We need to break up.
You know?
I want to break up.
What the fuck it's done.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
But it never works that way.
Usually the other person is like,
no,
we can work this out.
Then that's when you have to go al Madrigal.
Well listen while you're living together.
Yeah.
If you're living together,
it's hard.
Then it's hard.
You're not living together.
You have to go Al Madrigal what?
What now and now I don't have a told you that.
No,
I want to know to Alan had a breakup on time.
The Schick had some shit at his house.
He knew he was going to break up with her before we broke up.
He said,
he told her,
hey,
I'm going to come over tonight.
I think we need to talk about some things.
So she's like,
oh,
okay.
He fucking got a box,
packed all our shit up that was at his apartment,
walked over,
set the box down and said,
we've got to break up.
It's not working,
dude.
It was fucking clean.
Yeah,
that's,
that's easy for als.
Cause als a fucking maniac.
Like he does.
He,
when he has learned from maniacs,
no,
I love maniacs.
I've been kind of a maniac.
I are.
I am kind of a maintenance cycle because this cycle,
when it comes to breaking up,
uh,
they've never been good.
No,
it's good.
That's why you got to get through it.
If you live with them as harder,
if you don't live with them,
it's easy.
And that's why people fucking hang in and then they start cheating and they're
doing all of this fucking shit because they're basically mentally broken up.
So that could woman there essentially didn't even like as far as like an on an
emotional level.
Yeah.
Didn't fucking on a physical level she cheated,
but on an emotional level,
she didn't cause she already fucking broke up with guy.
She was done.
I find that Doug,
here's one,
here's one.
When you know the other person was already fucking other people.
Okay.
When someone breaks up with you and they're not even crying like that means I
already cried it out with their fucking friends.
They got no tears left and it's just like,
wow man,
this is how long has this shit?
Yeah.
You know,
I've never cried at a breakup.
I can't.
And they get guys don't crow all,
all the Google,
all my ex girlfriend,
his ex boyfriend,
they're like,
they cry,
they cry.
I was like,
cause they were fucking pussies.
Plus I was going to say the other words,
so I'm glad I did it,
but uh,
I would have known where,
this is how I know,
this is how I know this is how I know when it's done,
when they don't kiss you goodbye.
In the morning like,
cause I don't get off of work.
This is how I know it's done.
When when they're mad at you and you don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hi.
Yeah.
You're like,
ah.
And then they come in and they start doing the cold shoulder like,
and they're not fucking you.
It's just like any like good,
good,
Huh?
No,
you're right.
You're right.
Because then you start getting more productive because you got so much mental
time.
Oh,
this.
There's nothing worse than getting dumped,
but there's,
if you're the one breaking up with some,
I've,
dude,
I've been on both sides have broken hearts.
I've had my heart broken.
It's brutal.
I think that's why I'm so numb to it all now.
Yeah,
just fucking numb.
But I know,
I already know if,
if my,
if my marriage is,
I've worked out,
I would never get married again and I would just give my wife fucking everything
and then I'll let you go.
I'll go live in a fucking trailer.
My Buddy,
I'm not doing it again.
I'm not,
I'm not getting on the fucking ride again.
Yeah,
that's it.
Now just fucking wherever she lives.
I'll just drive the trailer down the street so I can still see my kids.
You can send them one of those air pods.
Do you ever see those things?
I don't know.
I would.
I would get a fucking,
I buy one of those VW buses.
No,
I get a studio.
Yeah,
get all the sports packages.
That'd be it.
I just,
I don't like tronic drum kit.
I just go back to what the fuck I had.
I'm actually shocked that you got married to be Ozzy.
You best thing I ever did.
One is great,
but it's weird.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if I'm ever getting married to be honest.
It's like I want to get married,
but I don't have to do it.
When you're ready.
Yeah.
I'm 42 I wasn't married.
I got married at 45 I got three more years I'm going to is great.
And then all of a sudden I'm like five years in,
I'm already going to turn 50 what the fuck am I going?
Where am I going?
What am I gonna go back to fucking club?
This Kay ladies,
you're looking for a bald red head.
God,
this is so sad.
I saw,
I see comics like that.
I don't want to mention any names,
but when you see,
oh,
believe me dude,
that was a motivation.
I'm not going to be the cliche.
It's so fucking sad.
I was like,
Oh God,
I don't,
uh,
so sounded like dating.
I don't,
I can't tell you I haven't dated since I just started doing stand up.
Really?
Does that makes any sense?
Like I'd meet girls and then we just started hanging out and then I sent an uh,
picking men.
That sounds weird.
You start wide.
We started hanging out and then I just picked them.
I was like,
oh,
this is the one I'm when I met with this one for a while.
Do they know that's what you're doing?
I don't know if they do.
Yeah.
You need to just listen to the best thing I have fucking Lauren is you just got
to fucking say what you're thinking.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
that's one of the reasons most of the women that I date like me,
cause I pretty much say what I'm thinking.
That's all.
How happy would you be if a woman did that?
That'd be fucking amazing.
I'm not saying like,
Hey,
you look ugly today.
I'm not saying that,
but I mean like,
you know,
I don't,
don't be mean,
but like just say,
dude,
I'm on what time?
I don't want to shed moment.
My relationship was me.
I had one of her friends was having a fucking birthday party.
Yeah.
Right.
The same night the Celtics and Lakers were playing like game of the NBA finals.
Okay.
She's like,
why are you doing Tuesday?
Right.
She doesn't talk like that.
That's just how it sounds in my head.
So she's,
what are you trying to say?
So I'm like,
I'm watching the game.
She's like,
does the pouty face,
you know,
manipulations and starts.
I hate the sexy voice and then the pout.
Right?
So if she's already tried to fucking tactics and not only is it a friend having
a birthday party,
it's like some fucking 1920s themed birthday party.
So I have to buy a fucking costuming.
A flapper.
Yeah.
I get addressed like I'm in the purple gang assumptions.
Right.
Okay.
So she goes,
do you want to go?
And I just,
I said,
no.
Yeah,
I liked that.
just what do you mean no?
And she goes,
why not?
I go,
it sounds horrific.
Yeah.
She goes,
and she laughed.
what do you mean?
She goes,
she's a friend to you as I go,
no,
she isn't.
I go,
she's your friend.
I've become friendly with her because you know her,
but she's not my friend.
I was sick this week.
She didn't know.
She didn't call.
She's not my friend,
and I just kept,
I just kept saying no,
and the more I said no,
the more she thought it was funny who?
She got frustrated.
Then she just started laughing.
I go,
I'm not going fucking down that dress like Charlie Chaplin.
I want to watch this game.
I don't want to fuck a dues.
So then she was,
she goes,
she can't,
she just,
she goes,
well,
what time does the game start?
I go,
you're such an asshole.
Yeah.
So now I got to go to this fucking party and then race back.
So then I just made a compromise.
I said,
all right,
the game fucking starts.
Are you wet?
And whatever.
I said,
here's the deal.
I go,
I will drive you there.
I will make an appearance.
I'm not dressing up and I'm leaving with plenty of fucking time to get back.
Yeah.
So the before the game starts.
All right.
And I don't want to eat
really.
I don't want to hear that.
Once again,
that's not how she sounds.
That's how she sounds when she says shit like that.
So she said,
fine.
So I fucking show up.
I drop this thing off and I show up.
There's all these fucking guys that dress like fucking Charlie Chaplin and Al
Capone and Shit.
And I come walking in with like a fucking Celtic shirt on dress style regular.
There's like,
hey,
you didn't dress up.
I said,
no,
no mom getting out of here in like 10 minutes.
And they go,
where are you going?
I go,
I'm going to watch the Celtics game.
And it's the finals,
this fucking hole.
And I remember the look on their faces and I this thick.
Yeah.
I felt awesome.
I bet they were so jealous,
dude.
You know what I do?
I've you how many times I've been the guy in the fucking check Chaplin outfit
then pretty hard about saying no.
Well,
I'll just say no.
You know what I mean?
But then I,
I'm pretty good about compromise though,
if they want to do something important to them.
So as long as I get to do what I want and then if they have something,
yeah,
I know.
I have a bunch of compromises.
I have the,
okay,
but you're driving and I'm drinking.
Oh,
okay.
Go to Brunch if you drive and I can drink,
that's thing I would,
you
know,
that is the,
I still don't,
I don't do brunch.
Yeah.
That's the one thing I fucking,
every time they walk,
there's a line and then they walk in,
they come on and go,
it's going to be 40 minutes is all right.
No,
it's not.
All right.
This is my fucking day too.
And it's a Sunday.
Fuck,
it's a sandwich.
You're going to get pissed,
dude.
What the fuck do we take them to on a weekend where we walk out and be like,
if they said it's going to be 40 minutes,
they would lose their shit.
Oh,
they would.
They would.
They would lose their fucking house.
Shit.
They would pop.
All right.
Do I have time to read?
How,
how far into this are we?
Fuck.
Alright.
Hour and 20.
We got to wrap this up.
Um,
I'll read the rest of these some of the time.
Kevin,
this was effortless.
Oh,
thank you.
You fucking hilarious.
Obviously funny and everybody should go out to the Improv and West Palm,
West Palm Beach.
More importantly,
listen to the podcasts and listen to the podcasts.
All I'm saying,
I'm saying podcasts.
We,
Kevin Shea,
one of the funniest dudes from the longest fucking time.
All right,
everybody go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on Thursday.